hey youtubers is Charlie so big Game of
Thrones season 8 update Joe Dempsie the
actor that plays Gendry did a big
preview of his character he said he has
a vastly expanded role during season 8
so we got to break it down if you're
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the Game of Thrones
videos now that we're moving into the
summer and they're finishing filming
season 8 they'll be done relatively soon
we actually got a real shot at getting
some work print footage by Comic Con
this July so I'll address that at the
end of the video too but he just went on
this big tear talking all about gantry
like guidry is probably one of the more
important but secondary characters in
season 8 just because of who he is his
bloodline your grace this is Gendry your
grace I'm Robert Baratheon son bastard
son he was meant to keep that to himself
just a real quick setup remember that
Cersei still controls the Iron Throne
they'll need to rebuild the kingdom and
as long as anyone from Team Jon and Team
Daenerys is still alive at the end of
all this and in power they can
legitimize him meaning that he could
help rebuild the kingdom so just very
important in addition to all the special
skills that he has in smithing the
biggest thing that he said during his
interview was it just don't assume that
because his part is bigger that he
survives to the end obviously that comes
with all the characters there's like a
little asterisk you have to put next to
their names like you know yes we really
love Jon Snow but he's a very tragic
character so you just have to remember
they Gendry survives does it
automatically mean that he and Arya are
gonna ride off into the sunset and be
happy together you will marry a high
Lord and rule his castle and your son's
shall be nice and princes and Lords
That's not me this is me reading some of
his quotes so rewind to season three he
says for me personally the only real
hope I had for the character was that he
would be there when the reckoning came
you got that sense even back in season
three that this was a show that was
building towards some incredible climax
so you just wanted to be there when it
all happened not even necessarily just
from a character point of view but from
a personal point of view the actor
himself like just as an actor regardless
of what his role was he wanted to be
there on set when they were making the
ending that end game so yeah I'm very
happy to be involved and be on set for
season eight
so that actually implies that he is
around for whatever like their big final
action set-pieces so what he's really
talking about is like the big final
battle not necessarily the final episode
but obviously there's gonna be tags with
all the characters that survive because
Dan and Dave are directing the final
episode they're not big action directors
Miguel sipoc Nick is directing the
episode before the finale
that's when like whatever the last big
battle will happen whether it's between
the forces of man and the forces of the
night king or if it's just at King's
Landing between Circe's remaining forces
in the north's remaining forces just
remember that everything is pointing
towards the final battle taking place
somewhere down near King's Landing it
just feels like that's where the series
would have its last big fight whether or
not that's actually where the series
ends it's just that we've been talking
about the iron throne for eight seasons
now so why wouldn't you end the series
there it also even ties back around with
Jon Snow's heritage in that running
plotline of the secret why did Ned keep
that secret he's the heir to the Iron
Throne so even though Winterfell is his
home King's Landing is really where the
culmination of this big story is gonna
take place we can talk about what
happens with winds of winter and book
changes in what possible different
interpretations that George are Barton
has about the climax of this story but
the book is still a long ways off so
we'll just have to piece together book
story while we're thinking about tv-show
story so Joe Dempsie goes on in his
interview and he says that they did tell
him that they would come back to Gendry
eventually when he rode off into the
distance they just didn't say when and I
think it various points along the way
Danny Davis plans for how the series
would
how many episodes they would do has
changed a little bit so that's probably
why you didn't hear more about Gendry
coming back sooner they just didn't know
exactly when they get to him and
sometimes actor availability becomes a
big problem so you just have to imagine
how bad it would have been if Joe
Dempsie would have been busy when they
were filming season seven it would have
been terrible he jokes about the
increased level of security the actors
aren't even allowed to be on social
media that much like they all have
profiles some of them tweet things out
but obviously can't be anything about
the show he also jokes that probably the
way to get secret's out of him is to get
him rip-roaring drunk so if you're a big
fan of Joe Dempsie and you run into him
at a bar you're welcome to try but
really liam Cunningham is kind of like
the Tom Holland Mark Ruffalo of The Game
of Thrones universe like the person that
just lets stuff out bit by bit that
gives us an idea for what's going on so
if you're a little confused about why
Gendry has a much bigger story even
though they only have six episodes and
all the actors are in the same place
meaning that there's fewer potential
time for each of the actors to get like
really big moments by themselves just
remember that the episode length has
been expanded to what you would call
feature-length like movie length that's
really anything beyond 60 minutes normal
Game of Thrones episodes like you go
back a couple seasons or like 52 to 55
minutes so bare minimum you're talking
an extra 10 to 20 minutes per episode
which doesn't sound like a lot but
really what that is is that's like three
or four more really big scenes with
different characters so that's how you
get more Gendry plus because most of the
actors are in one of two locations most
of those big scenes that they get as
part of their storylines will be with
other big characters like they'll have
conjoined storylines so like if you have
a big Jamie scene it will probably take
place with bran or some of the other
main characters so instead of just
getting Jamie by himself in just getting
Jon Snow and Daenerys by themselves
you're getting a lot of that all at the
same time and you have to remember where
Gendry left off so he was last seen at
eastwatch-by-the-sea he was one of the
first people back me that he was
probably one of the first people out so
he probably makes it back to Winterfell
sometime during the first episode but
just sort of plotting things out like if
you're thinking about that first episode
the really big stuff will probably
happen first like Jon Snow and Daenerys
making it to Winterfell
is the big thing for the beginning of
season 8 and then everybody else showing
up like Jamie showing up Gendry showing
up having that bird union with aria
Jaime pledging his support to Daenerys
and Jon Snow
Jaime having that awkward reunion with
bran hey remember that time that I
pushed you out of that window so really
there's only a couple episodes till
Miguel subhanak directs episode 3 which
is where I think the first really big
battle will take place so talking about
kendrys storyline what is he going to do
that's super important what is his
importance to the story because you only
have a couple of episodes before the
night king arrives with his first big
horde at Winterfell
so first real big prediction we've all
been waiting for Gendry and brand to
sort of magic up the recipe for Valyrian
steel we have dragons
we have dragon glass we can probably
reforge Valyrian steel but the problem
is is that it would take a long time to
teach that to other people
and make enough weapons for the other
armies that are sitting outside
Winterfell waiting for the night Kings
army to arrive so the whole idea with
the dragon glass mining at the end of
last season at Dragonstone is that they
would just be passing out dragon glass
daggers to all the infantrymen anybody
that's gonna have a chance of meeting a
white or white Walker in combat mostly
thinking about the unsullied the
Dothraki because they're kind of like
Daenerys infantry and cavalry right now
so hopefully that addresses the
potential for making Valyrian armor or
special Valyrian weapons I mean it's
always possible but again just does not
seem like there's enough time like you
could cover one of the dragons in
Valyrian armor wouldn't that be badass a
dragon wearing dragon armor but it would
take forever to find that and I would
not be surprised if Daenerys loses one
more of her dragons but I do think you
know we talked about thematically
they'll probably a separate dragon video
where I talk about this but the Dragons
will lay more eggs that will eventually
be more dragons like this won't be the
end of all things magic and Dragons even
though it's the culmination of the story
it she's already lost Viserion but the
other big thing like I said the Guidry
can help out with is on a political
level rallying support for their cause
because of his bloodline they trot him
out is a Baratheon all the former
Baratheon supporters are much more
likely to side with Daenerys when things
are done or if they need to raise new
forces during the middle of the season
so
remember we talked about the issue of
jon snow's parentage about how the Lords
of the north collectively hate Daenerys
Targaryen because she's a Targaryen they
will probably freak out when they find
out that Jon Snow is part Targaryen but
it makes sense that they live through
Robert's rebellion they're much more
likely to go along with whatever plans
that they have if they have the son of
Robert Baratheon speaking up for Jon
Snow and Daenerys so I don't think it's
gonna be too big of a point hopefully
they don't drag it out too much
getting to the Arya of it all I know
there are a lot of Gendry Aria questions
is because there's so much unfinished
business between those two characters I
could be your family but now Arya is a
completely different character she
doesn't want to be the lady of a castle
but the only way I see her actually sort
of like riding off into the sunset so to
speak with gander II is if she pays the
price that George our Martin has teased
there are rules about how they use their
skills they don't just go around killing
anybody that they want or there's a
price to pay so George our Martin teased
that because she's sort of a rogue
faceless person now
she didn't even complete the training
the only way I see her riding off into
the sunset with Gendry is if she
completely loses her sight and she needs
someone to help her so she just goes to
live with Gentry so let me know in the
comments all your Gander e predictions
Joe Dempsie says Gendry much bigger in
season eight how did they use him what
is his political importance and how do
you think they end his story does he
become the Lord of storms end or does he
wind up doing something more mundane
like just becoming a blacksmith
somewhere just living a normal life the
other really cool thing the Game of
Thrones people just announced is that
they're doing a 4k re-release of season
1 meaning that all the seasons of Game
of Thrones will eventually get 4k
masters so I'll do a giveaway for that
when we get a little bit closer but
while you wait for everything click here
to listen to Sean beans new interview
talking about Ned Stark and click here
to start getting ready for a West world
which is starting later this month thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
you